all right I hope that every
can you hear me there
it's very nice to see so many of you
come here out what could probably be
considered one of the most nerdy
subjects for a nerdy population in the
same way that you probably wouldn't want
to go to an accounting talk on a
developer conference I'm really happy to
see that you guys want to go to a
privacy talk on a developer conference
so if you're not here for the talk on
privacy and gdpr then I'm sorry to
disappoint you but I think you will
enjoy it anyway my name is Johannes
Broadwell I work as a developer at
suppress area and we're a huge
consultancy and one of the really fun
things about working as a developer in a
large organization today is that you get
to interact with people that have other
fields of expertise and one of the areas
that I've had a chance to interact with
my colleagues has been in the area of
privacy and if any of you work for
consultancy you probably have a feeling
that every time you go to one of your
customers one of your clients everybody
is talking about privacy and gdpr and
they have these meetings and they have
the gdpr
working group then they're over in here
doing their things and most companies
have as their main TDP our strategy we
need to have a lot of meetings we need
to have a lot of people in those
meetings we need to write down a lot of
documents a lot of task list and then we
really need to pray that somebody is
going to execute some of those tasks it
is one strategy I don't think it's the
most effective one but probably the even
more popular strategy is to kind of
politely express concern that you don't
know what's going on and that you don't
know what to do and I'm here today to
kind of get people to try and calm down
a little bit about it fits then I got
some news last week that freaked me out
a little so I don't know how come we can
stay but we'll take a best-effort
so there's three parts to my talk first
as a developer so here hair is a
developer works with software
development as my
of you as a developer gdpr will concern
you it will affect your work and it will
affect your project and second as a
human who here is a human most of you a
privacy is actually something that you
should care about as a human because we
live in dangerous times so I will try
and convince you of those two things
that this matters to you and then I will
try and give you a roadmap to navigate
through the gdpr
regulations so that you can impress
people at GDP our party's alright I'll
start with with a story from my own life
the story never happened but it's true
anyway this is a so in addition to
working for suppressed area I organized
the conference mobile era which is in
November this year in Oslo you should go
and after you organize the conference
it's very nice to gather the team
together and have a dinner together
we're we're like decompressing from the
conference and things like this so we
want to see who's coming to the dinner
and we want to make sure that they've we
know people's dietary preference so that
we don't accidentally serve the wrong
food so I only drink craft beer so
that's an important preference when we
choose the place to go and then Allah
who works at the conference voluntary
information that he is a vegetarian hold
on a moment is that personal information
so according to the GDP are the general
data protection regulation personal
information our personal data means any
information referring to an identified
or identifiable natural person which is
called the data subject so yes the fact
that Allah is a vegetarian is personal
information and just it affect my little
Google form that I'm using to collect
this data
well the gdpr says that it applies to
the price own personal data wholly or
partly by automated means which means
any computer system it does make
exceptions for private use like in a
household or
or personal situation but an
organization is definitely not exempt so
this is actually use of personal data
that's unregulated under the GD P R Oh
now not all data is the same so my
friend oli here he doesn't eat pork so
what do you guys think you know about
Olli now and somebody's religious belief
is a special category of personal data
that triggers special clauses and need
for protection so now we have to protect
now we have to think even more about
who's getting access to this data there
are all the categories of special data
anyone want to guess which what other
kind of special data is especially
protected health information yeah so the
fact that cardi here is allergic to
shellfish that is information regarding
regarding our health okay so we have a
special category of data there as well
and so when we put a process personal
data what do we have to think about now
luckily when you and learn how to read
the regulation which I will teach you
later
you will know that your obligations
according to the GDP are listed in
article 5 of the GDP are so when you're
processing someone's personal data you
have to do it with a lawful basis you
have to have a legal reason for doing it
you have to do it for a specific purpose
you only have to use it for that purpose
you have to keep the data as small as is
needed for the purpose of collect more
data than you need you have to make sure
that the data is correct and up-to-date
you have to delete the data when it's no
longer needed and you have to make sure
that you keep the data secure so those
are your obligations so we have to think
about that and most of this goes through
that we have to communicate to people
that we're using the data which is also
described quite well in the GDP right
what do we have to communicate to people
we have to be transparent about the fact
that
someone's personal they didn't let them
know what why we're pressing their
personal data and how they can control
that processing and then there is the
sort of elephant in the room so where
are we storing the data here we're
storing the data on Google's good on
Google and Google servers are kind of
transparent to us we don't know where
they are and the did gdpr
you cannot transfer personal data to
areas outside of the EU or the European
Economic Area unless there are certain
safeguards in place so there's a
likelihood that we're exporting the data
here to the United States that's also
regulated so okay so we're having where
we are posting personal data we don't
know why I what legal basis we're
processing it we don't know how we're
producing it we're exporting it outside
of the EU in conclusion we have with we
actually have a problem even with this
shitty little application here this
silly little form we have to think about
these things oh so where do we begin
well as with all difficult things we
start with taking big deep breath and
then break it down and try and fix each
of these individual things so let's
start with the simplest thing the basis
of processing we need to have a legal
reason for processing someone's data
there are in the GDP our six reasons why
you can process someone's data it's
because they consented to it it's
because you're required in order to
fulfill a contract that they vented to
it is because you're legally obligated
because you're protecting vital
interests because of something I don't
remember or because you have a
legitimate interest in processing the
data the legitimate interest is one of
the biggest sort RIF trip holes in the
whole GD P R so what is our legal basis
for processing this data about the
people who come to our little dinner
I think in this case the legal basis is
that of consent we're asking people is
it okay if I process your data and
hopefully they want us to process their
data because they want the dinner and
for almost all kinds of volunteer
situations you want you're forced to use
consent as your basis of processing
what's important about asking someone
for consent is that under the GD P R it
has to be informed and freely given so
that means that it has anyone had their
badge scanned at the conference here
okay so do you know what they were going
to use the data that they scanned a data
for when they scanned your badge did
they tell you why they were going to use
it yes
oh okay so they wanted to know well that
was when you entered the conference
right right yes but you can also do that
at stance of like a booths but in this
case we're I'm assuming that when when
and github scan this it was because they
wanted to communicate with me via email
and and I mean I am okay with that so
it's it's not a problem but they hadn't
really told me what they were going to
use the personal data for and that is
actually not illegally obtained consent
so when you start looking at these
things there are various there's small
problems there anywhere and and when you
think about it the fact that somebody's
collecting your email address and you
don't really know what they're going to
use it for and you start to think about
it that doesn't feel so comfortable you
would like to know I mean you're
probably okay with it but you'd like to
know and you have a right to know so in
our case we have to make sure that we
get a consent from our from from the
people who register it for Ted dinner
second we have to give information about
what we're going to do with the data and
I told you that sort of the overall
rules are in GDP our article twelve
article 13 there's a very nice checklist
as developers would like checklist where
it says you have to tell who collects
the data so what's the organization on
the other end and why are they
collecting the data who will get the
data will they give it to someone else
how long will we keep the data and you
and we also have to inform them this is
your data and you can contact us in this
in this way in order for us to delete a
data if you no longer want us to have it
so you have to give them a way to
exercise their right to the control of
the data so I'll update my my form I'll
say we'll use information to make the
reservation and then we will delete it
this is an important bit of information
for people to have the information will
only be used by the party committee then
we know who's going to see the
information and we will anonymize it
when we place the order so that so the
restaurant won't know who
the vegetarian probably will have a good
guess but at least not through us and I
also have a little consent form and as a
practical matter when you have a
checkbox that says I consent to whatever
probably that checkbox needs to be by
default not checked it should always be
of a active action to consent
so a default check checkbox is not okay
now I'm not a lawyer I'm a developer I
don't know what I'm talking about don't
use this as a template but know that
there should probably be some text as
clearly as possible telling people what
you're going to use their information
for now did this question about Google
can we send the data to Google the
general rule is that you can only
transfer data to a country if that
country has a was called an adequate
data protection law so Canada has very
strong privacy laws so probably you can
export data from Europe to Canada now
the United States on the other hand it's
sort of a rogue nation it is really not
a very good at respecting privacy
especially not in these days so you
probably cannot freely export data to
the United States so then it's not you
cannot generally export it so it has to
be something specific about your
relationship with Google this is called
a appropriate safeguard you have to have
something in place in order to make sure
it's safe to export to Google so they
have so Google have to guarantee you
that they have taken safeguards these
are called binding corporate rules
sounds very legalese so they are which
basically means they have to well here
it says well they have to basically tell
you that they will report a respective
rights of the data subjective people
will register the information about they
have to to commit to cooperating with
the data protection a
agencies in the European countries and
they have to commit to only process the
data as you instruct them so do you guys
think Google has thought about this both
all of the big cloud providers have
serious efforts thinking about GDP are
so Google Amazon and Microsoft
especially have both a guidance for you
to help you to improve employment
privacy correctly and a lot of
information about their commitment to
fulfilling privacy requirements and
these are some of the documents from
Google's so a in this case they have see
they're having data protection
commitments and these commitments are
generally in accordance to the GDP our
so actually we that was just a scare we
can actually probably store the data on
Google at least if they do what they say
they do and of course Google has never
done anything wrong wrong when it comes
to privacy actually Google has a record
when it comes to privacy the biggest
fine for violation of the GDP are goes
to Google from France as of January they
got fined there 50 million euros for EM
in this case if a lack of transparency
inadequate information and lack of valid
consent regarding ads personalization so
ok they have committed to following the
GDP are but you might not want to trust
them totally but as someone who's using
them as a data processor where you're
controlling the data it's probably okay
so in our case it's most definitely okay
okay back to my little registration form
for our dinner there is actually another
commitment which is sort of an umbrella
commitment which is that when you're
pressing personal data you have to
taking into consideration the costs the
risks the state-of-the-art all of these
things you have to make
a good effort to minimize how much data
you process this is based on so here is
a little bit of that so you have to take
appropriate technical and organizational
measures for ensuring that by default
only personal data which is necessary
for each specific purpose of the
processing are processed it I mean if
you read a lot of technical
documentation if you've read the HTTP
specification this is nothing right you
can read this so what it means is that
do we need to know that somebody is a
vegetarian in order to process their
order in order to reserve to make a
dinner reservation for them do we need
to know that actually we don't we just
need to know what to order for them and
an old principle from of privacy this is
from Canada and kevorkian this is part
of the Canadian privacy laws I have one
of they have seven principles to privacy
by design and one of my favorite one is
to say let's embed privacy into the
design which is to make it a sign where
we're thinking about how to protect how
to minimize how much information we get
in our case let's just ask people what
they want to eat from the menu and in
this case and so the general
recommendation is to replace like free
text fields text input fields with
choices because in this case this bean
burger here this is actually really
delicious so right now I think I'm gonna
go for the bean burger I'm not a
vegetarian and I'm really now I'm really
looking forward to the dinner so it's
even a better design because it makes us
happier as well so by thinking about
what's the information we really need
and how does that fit our design we can
actually make a better user experience
and give everybody better privacy so
that is privacy by design and to some
extent this is a theoretical example but
I've run this example through with the
Norwegian Data Protection Agency and
they say yes this is definitely
something that is covered by the GDR
even though it is it's
small shitty little example and this
thing with having checkboxes or a radio
button instead of a text field is
actually something that has been basis
for a legal decision the oslo city was
fined two million kronor in actually I
think that it hasn't been finalized they
will be fined two million kronor right
about now for a system that's used for
communicating between teachers and
parents of school students and one of
the complaints from the Data Protection
Agency was that they didn't need to have
a text field here where people could say
things like he's got a flu or his god
there's depression in the family or
whatever personal information they could
put in that field so so the fuse of a
text field where it wasn't necessary was
remarked it wasn't that that was the
important part of the decision but it
was a remark in this decision and I used
to say two weeks ago I would say the
basic idea of gdpr and and this is still
true is that you should process people's
data in the way they want to be
processed if people so if they scan your
badge and then they forward the
information to all the head hunters in
the world even if you sign something on
a on a consent yes I consent to this you
it was probably not what you wanted
right so if you're pressing the data in
a way that they probably don't want
you're probably also in violation of the
law if they don't know how you're
processing the data if they would be
surprised by how you're president they
say you're probably also in violation of
the law so if you process the data in
the way that they want you're probably
okay if you're processing the data in
the way that they have expressed that
they want you're very likely to be okay
that's what I would have said two weeks
ago but last week there was a decision
made in Denmark that I still don't know
how to get my head quite around there
was a Danish furniture company called id
design they got a fine of 1.5 million
Danish kroner it's not the end of the
world but it is a substantial fine
and the problem was that they had failed
to have routines to delete customers and
they had 380,000 or so customer records
actually they had 800,000 customer
records but they had a reason to keep
450,000 of them so they got fined for
keeping more information than they
needed it was not so what did they do
wrong it was it was not sensitive data
this was people's contact information
and purchase history it was not
illegally collected it this was
information that people had registered
as they bought their products in order
to have the warranties they claimed
later be processed so that was not it it
was not misused in any way it was simply
that they didn't have the routines to
delete it when they should have that is
all that they as far as I can tell
that's all that they did wrong and
that's um to be frank I think it was a
little bit harsh but they did violate
the regulation okay so how many of you
think that you have some data in the
system that could have been and perhaps
should have been deleted by now because
it's not necessary I think pretty much
all of you right so at this point in
time I kind of have to step back and
think you know is this stuff really
necessary why do we have these
regulations why do we need to think
about this why do they need to pick on
these small things and that's that's the
second part of the talking this one is a
little bit harder so I think so I hope
we'll be okay but I'll start on the
light note when if you start reading the
gdpr which we will soon you will start
by reading what's called recitals which
are sort of considerations behind the
law they're not actually the law but
they're the reason the law was there and
one very important consideration behind
the law is the EU once the economies of
the
of the European countries to converge
they want to have what's called a so
they want to remove obstacles of flow to
personal data they want to make you into
a more coherent business area and this
is a good there's a good business and
technical reason for this because that
means that you can use the same
standards to apply to how you process
data in all of Europe and as this was
becoming more and more clear for example
thought works which many of you probably
know if I put on there on there a
technology radar as an idea to host L
all personal identifiable information
that's what Americans call personal data
to hold to to host all of this in the EU
because those are the high standards so
if you're complying to European
standards you're probably compliant to
standards all over the world that's a
business advantage for for Europe this
is good for everybody who wants to run
data centers in Europe it means that
we're the gold standard when it comes to
to your hosting if you if your hosts
here you're okay that's and this sort of
business advantage is is valuable
valuable and important but that's sort
of the more boring part the more human
part is that the first words in the GDP
are is that the protection of natural
person in relation to the pricing
personal data is a fundamental right
it's part of the European human rights
charter it is considered a personal
human right and EU once through the GDP
are to have a focus on that in our day
and time we need to process data
responsibly which and this does affect
companies so to their credit very soon
after the GDP are became on everybody's
mind Facebook decided to roll out a
global privacy settings hub so they are
responding to GDP are with improving our
privacy which is very good but speaking
of Facebook of course if
talk about facebook without talking
about cambridge analytical so how many
of you have heard of the Cambridge
analytical scandal
how many knew of you know what it what
it was all about I thought so so and and
this is kind of interesting because it
might surprise you and I'd like to go
into detail about what actually happened
so this is in a nutshell
so Facebook allows certain apt to have
more privileges than other apps and this
is often done for research so one of
these researchers was a guy named
Alexander Cogan who worked I think at
Cambridge University and he made a one
of those stupid like personality test
apps this is your personal life I think
it was good this is your digital life is
what it was called and then people could
could play this game and they could
consent to having their personal data
consent they have collected by the app
but not only their own personal data but
also the personal data of their friends
so by about a hundred thousand people
consenting to this I'm Alexandra Cogan
was able to collect data about a hundred
million people or thereabout it's a huge
data set this is about what what they've
liked what pictures have shared where
what contact information like what
address they have on Facebook their
email addresses all of the things that
you can see about your friends on
Facebook and Alexandra Cogan shared this
data with this company Cambridge
analytical and there is a really
fascinating a talk that I watched a by
this is the CEO of Cambridge analytic a
he's also Alexander Nicks I think and he
this is this is from a conference where
he tries to sell their product so they
made a product based on this this is
actually their marketing video from that
conference this so this is not this is
their propaganda and this was just after
the Republican primary in the United
States where Cambridge analytical had
assisted the campaign of Ted Cruz
and now they wanted to sell their
technology to the campaign of Donald
Trump and this is their sales pitch and
you can see it on Fair on YouTube this
is one of my favorite pictures from this
which is that they had records about
individual voters with where they were
and what sort of personality type they
classified into so they would say here
we have someone whose high high
neuroticism and consciousness they live
in this in a swing district in a swing
state and we will target advertisement
to that person's email address that
looks something like this the second
demand isn't just right it's the
insurance policy and and this is another
person who is close and agreeable and we
will target and they who also live in a
swing district in a in a important
estate and we will target this ad to
that person based on their email address
that we have collected does that sound
like a fair use of your personal data
because one of your friends clicked I
consent to some stupid online game so
this is what happens in our weather this
is what would happen even more without
gdpr and with the GDP our Europe has
chosen to take a stand but there are
other apart paths that you could go in
China they have this the Social Credit
System which has been a little bit in
the news and let's see I forgot to test
this video and so we'll see if it works
yeah okay we don't have sound people who
travel without a ticket or behave
disorderly or smoke in public areas will
be punished according to regulations and
your behavior will record it in the
individual credit information system to
avoid a negative record of personal
credit please follow the relevant
regulations and help with the orders of
the Train and on and at the station and
this is supported through
massive set of video surveillance
cameras and facial recognition that keep
track of things like if you're crossing
the street on the red light and then
they make a little note of it this is
for all of China but the westernmost
province of China
chin yang is has a very large Muslim
population and the Chinese Communist
Party doesn't like Muslims so here they
are surveying everybody who live in this
region and they from air do things like
finding out if you go to mosque on
Fridays and they keep a track of that
and if you have gone on what's called a
unofficial hive so if you go on a
pilgrimage without getting approval from
the Chinese Communist Party they keep
track of that and in the Kim Jong
Province there are believed to be
millions of people in what can only be
described as concentration camps so this
is our world today and we've seen this
sort of path before it can go very very
wrong
this machine it's called the D home AG
tabulated d11 it's Deutsche holida from
machinery main shaft is what they are my
exam for and this machine was
instrumental to revolutionising census
data in the early 1900s because like
before the 1900 1900 s it would take
years to get census data to know how
many people live in your country
basically and where the use of these
punch cards machines they the 1933
German census was completed in record
time and with a much higher fidelity
than they've either ever had before this
is a folk son better of shahe saloon I
think that means a census in German so
this is the kind of cards that they use
and this line here upside down is
religion and what they found in the 1933
census was that
they thought there was about half a
million Jews living in Germany at that
point in time but they found through the
census that there was about two million
Jews which really helped the propaganda
of the German state at that point in
time even more they could use things
like this is the dijo mag card sorting
machine they could use that to find out
which cards had an individual property
and they knew the address so that is
very helpful when you want to take these
people and transport them to somewhere
else so that is where the idea that data
protection that your privacy is a basic
human right it is because when we look
back at the last half-century from the
time we started using machines to
process personal data people have gotten
hurt so what will we look back at half a
century from now think about how did we
use that data how did we how do we treat
people okay that's I think yeah this is
not the most joyous part of the time of
the talk and I think we need to lighten
the mood a little bit so let's break
open and read the general data
protection regulation shall we that
sounds like much more enjoyable right
now right okay so this word regulation
in the context of EU regulation is a act
of the European Union that becomes
automatic law in all of the countries so
that means that the unlike a directive
which is where the EU says you have to
make a law in your country to fulfill
this directive the regulation applies
directly and uniformly so that means it
is a law across all of Europe and there
aren't so many of them they're not very
well liked I didn't find a comprehensive
list but when you look at list of EU
regulations on Wikipedia you get to I
think 41 pages just about now and I
think at least most of us
happy about this one this is the roam
like home regulation that was actually a
regulation at home that is when all of
the teller companies came and said oh
you can now go on vacation and you can
use your data all across Europe as with
the same rates as in Norway aren't we
nice but you're not nice you were
required by law to do that so that's so
so we already know that regulation has
benefited us so that's good and so let's
start reading it this is when you go to
the European Commission and start
looking for the GDP I'll this is the
text of the GDP our so okay are you guys
ready regulation year 2016 7 6 to 79 of
the european parliament and of the
council of 27 5l 2016 on the protection
of natural person with regarding to the
processing of personal data and the free
movement of such data and repealing
directly 95 46 EC the general data
protection regulation the European
Parliament and the Council of the
European Union having regarded to the
treaty of the functioning of the
European Union and in particular to
article 60 in thereof everybody's still
following alone having regard to the
proposal from the European Commission
after transmitting of the draft
legislative act to the national
parliaments having a regard to the
opinion of the European Economic and
Social Committee I don't think this text
was written for me let's skip ahead a
little bit so if we go to the next page
we'll start to be numbered list that's
generally a good sign on those numbers
then we know that this is sort of a
specific thing so the protection of
natural person in relation to the
processing of personal data is
fundamental right article Oh this also
doesn't sound very can create does it so
this is what's called recitals it is
sort of the pre the prefix to the whole
of the TDP are there's 173 of these
points I'm not going to read all of them
but I did when I first started reading
the gdpr and I don't recommend it
because that's not where you start even
though that's where the texts start okay
here's some more of this so the the
first sort of takeaway is that when
anyone asks you does this have anything
to do with GDP registers have an
privacy concerns you should go to GD
power in for the GDP are infinite EU
this is and one of a few sites that
takes the official PDF and they split it
up with a nice table of contents and
hyperlinks and they start with the part
that you that is actually legally
binding which is the articles so I
started looking at the recycles but it's
the articles that's really that's
binding and we will look at that in a
little bit there are other alternatives
as well so you'll see this address on
top of here all the time so if you
didn't write it down you can do it
afterwards so here is one example called
exported the GD P R which is an app and
that one has the advantage that it has
the text in all official languages so it
contains in a region translation of the
text as well the GD power is split into
11 chapters or the articles were split
into 11 chapters of those chapters the
first five are the ones that concern
most of us and after that it's more of
sort of the legal mechanics of it like
what is the role of the Data Protection
Agency things like this and the first
one is about sort of over the general
provisions that where it applies the
general principles this one is very
important the rights of the data subject
which is sort of it should feed into
your product backlog because everything
this hair is something that people that
you register information about the data
subjects they should be able to exercise
the rights here so there is a nice list
of requirements that goes straight into
your product backlog what
responsibilities you have as a data
processor a data controller the person
deciding and the person executing the
processing and this part about transfer
a personal data which you don't really
have to read it's very seldom that you
have to go into detail about it so it's
this bit that's most important but I'll
make a little detour so I said that the
last part isn't also important but sort
of can I say regulation port the rate
that the part that everybody gets
excited about the titillating part is
article 83 which you might have heard
about which is
you can be subject to an administrative
fee that says a punishment of up to 20
million euros or in a or up to 4 percent
of the total annual worldwide turnover
turnover not revenue this is as a Google
got away very lucky here they could have
gone a lot higher so people like to pull
this out because it's exciting and it
just means that you know regulation can
regulate a regulators can really break
the back of companies if they wish to
but it's not the important part
yes price lists there is there is a one
called
I think enforcement tracker comm
something like this it's a website that
has a list of all of the fights that
have been given so far that's where
you'll find this danish case and you'll
find those with the oslo city case and
the google case so there are there's
about once per week that show up there
and 50 million is really an outlier
so the important that the part that you
really want to understand about the gdpr
and the part it is kind of inspiring as
well as chapter two about principles and
then you need to understand the rights
of the data subject what should people
be allowed to do when you store data
about them and then this is more rights
of data subjects and then your
obligation as a data processor so what
what is a responsible way of handling
data so let's break it down a little bit
what do you need to do I already showed
you article 5 of the GD P R and it is by
many considered sort of the my miniature
GD P R if you understand this you
understand the idea of Gd P R so we've
been through some of this before I'll
repeat it because it's important you
have to process it lawfully you have to
have a legal reason for processing you
have to process first best
if I'd explicit and legitimate purpose
and you only have to use it for that
purpose so you cannot collect data for
one reason and use it for another reason
you have to have as little data as you
need no more data than you need and you
have to take steps to make sure that it
is accurate so you cannot say that
somebody has a bad credit rating when
they don't for example oops
and yeah I'm the one that's under here
you also have to take steps to make sure
that you're pressing the data in a
secure way so you're in trusted data and
you have to live up to that trust those
are those other things let's break it
down a little bit more so you your to-do
list is to know what is the lawfulness
what is the basis of your processing why
we're pressing in this data how do we
facilitate the rights of the people that
we're processing data for and how can we
do it responsibly three things the
lawfulness we've been through it consent
and necessary for a contract compliance
with the legal obligation protect vital
interest so a the the performance of
tasks carried out by the generally the
official authority vested by the control
this means if you're an official
organization that has a given a task to
post data like than welfare
administration you can present data and
according to about us and for legitimate
interest and a good example of a
legitimate interest is if you're logging
usage of your system like you're doing
access logging is probably a legitimate
use of first people's personal data in
that case your users do because it's
necessary to to protect the freedom of
others and make the system run well and
I mentioned that I like to focus on
consent it is what's most often so in
the general case if you're if you don't
have a legal reason to use stay
therefore someone you have to ask them
for their permission and this is this is
one of the things that's interesting to
bring up a sort of a GDP our party thing
which is you can say well according to
GDP our article 7 sub clause for the
data has to be a that the consent has to
be freely given so if you are requiring
a consent to use data for this purpose
in order to give someone access to this
functionality that's unrelated that was
not a freely given consent so it's
probably not valid in accordance to the
GDP our that's what it says in this
article this this paragraph here so
that's a nice that always lightens the
mood at these discussions
so a you need to so in most cases if you
if you don't have a legal reason to keep
the data you're probably going to ask
have to ask people for permission and
they have to understand what you're
asking for permission to do and they
have to be able to say no if they don't
want it otherwise it's not a legally
obtained consent most lawyers say if you
have an other basis for processing than
consent then use that because people can
withdraw their permission which is kind
of annoying so you collect someone's
data and they say oh I gave you
permission I don't know I no longer give
you permission please delete my data
that can be very annoying especially if
you've used that data in many downstream
systems also but a you need to know
about the trade-off so you need to know
that there is a trade-off you don't
necessarily need to know what it is in
your case when some when you're
collecting when somebody is collecting
data about you you have certain rights
you have the right to know that they
have collected the data about you and
you have the right to in general see
what data they have collected about you
and you have the right to ask them to
correct data that they have recorded
about you if you feel is wrong so a
rectified data you have the right to ask
them to delete a data so here are some
of these I'm going to skip some of the
it was I'm gonna get back to this and
then I and then one of my favorite ones
you have the right to get the data in a
structured commonly used and machine
readable format the right to data
portability this is this is really cool
that means that I can make my milk a
usage graph I can go to the grocery
stores that have these loyalty programs
and I can ask for their purchasing
history on me and then I can see how
much milk I bought every week and I can
make my graph out of it this is super
cool so that means if you're running a
company then the people that you
registering information about your data
subjects they can request a export on on
a machine readable format something like
Jason XML CSV you you get to choose when
you export so that's that's okay
and and that's kind of annoying if
people come to you and ask for expert
ability but it's really cool if you can
get your cost your competitors customer
to go to them and ask them to export
their data let's say if you're an
insurance company and you say hey if you
go to our competitor and you export your
data and you establish a customer
relationship with us we will give you
the bonus based on your history with
them and that's that's a very good way
to get sort of an insight into your cost
your your competitors as well so and and
if if you know that your competitors
aren't doing their GDP our duties very
well it's a good way to distract them
from competing with you now this is a
little bit vicious a little bit evil but
it is a part of the intention behind the
GDP are is to enable businesses to do it
to compete more freely now there's one
more thing that I want to that I skipped
which is extremely important which we
tend to forget so I showed your article
13 has a nice checklist
what you need to tell people when you
collect data about them article 14 what
if you get the data from a third party
so let's say that you are buying a plane
ticket to yourself and your spouse then
you have then the error airline has
gotten information not just about you
but also about your spouse and your
spouse has right to that information
let's say that you are a you are a
company that collects data for sales
management and you deliver that data to
your marketing organization which is
legally not the same organization the
marketing organization has to let
everybody know that they got this data
even if they got even if you got the
consent to transport it so if you get
data about someone from someone else you
have to tell the data subjects and this
can be pretty hard because you don't
necessarily have a point of contact and
I think this is one of the it is one of
those things that's very reasonable if
somebody collects data about me even if
I didn't give it to them I should have a
right to know but it's pretty hard to do
that as a company to make sure that that
happens okay so we're going here I'm
gonna skip this one because it's too
scary but I'm going to go to this one so
let's say that I transfer data that I
got data from my users and I transfer
that data to another company and then
they told me to delete them from their
system were told me to correct their
that I've registered the wrong country
for them I have to to a
notify everybody that I exported the
data to about this as well so and this
might also come into fact if you're
storing data in backups and if you have
a reporting system outside there you
have to make sure that all of the data
is deleted everywhere and all of the
data is corrected everywhere this is so
when you get a requirement to erase data
or a correct data you have to distribute
the changes this so I think people are
making a little bit of notes this is
this is harder than I thought alright
now the last part so we've talked about
you have to have a legal basis for
processing you have to respect the
rights of the people that you're
processing data for and then you have to
process that data in a responsible way
and I'm going to show a few things that
are required for that I mentioned to you
already article 25 is one of those
important article 1 articles and it says
taking to account the state of the art
which is a very nice phrase because it
means this moves as as we get better the
requirement is higher the cost of
implementation the risk to the rights of
the person so if it's something that's
very expensive to implement but it
doesn't protect against the substantial
risk it's not required and yeah then you
have to take appropriate measures which
means that you have to think about what
is the appropriate methods to minimize
the data that you're processing this is
a obligation that you have so you have
to think about this words what's the
state of the art what are the risks to
the people that you're registering what
is the cost of implementing and what
will then be the appropriate measures to
implement that's about minimizing data
and like we talked about asking for
people's menu choice and ask instead of
asking for dietary restrictions it's a
way of minimizing the day as a company
the process person vaycay you have to
keep
occurred of every system this processing
personal data what sort of personal data
is processing who's good access to it if
there's any special categories of
personal data like medical information
or religious beliefs how long you're
storing it for so basically if you're if
you're an architect and nobody listens
to you and let's say we have to have
this list of all our systems then you
actually have now a legal reason that
you are required by law to have a list
of all your data processing activities I
mentioned you have to minimize data but
you also have to secure data so for all
of the security architects it can't get
anyone to listen to you this is your
this is your apparel your article you
have to consider the state of the art
the cost of implementation the risks to
the people that you're processing and
you have to take appropriate measures
that gives a level of security
appropriate to the risk which basically
means if you don't know / you shouldn't
be processing personal data it's that's
a okay summary of it and it does mean
that in situations like when the Osler
when oslo city had implemented
insufficient their vulnerability was
insecure direct object access you know
this one so you go to website you see in
the URL there is something that looks
like a customer number you try and
change it you see someone else's data
that one that that is a repeating one so
don't do that if you do that you will
get a fine and and the funny thing about
that one is that those are the ones that
the bug hunters go for right
a similar one in Bergen was discovered
by a by 14 year old I think it was and
that's kind of embarrassing to have a 14
year old cause you to get a fine of 2
million through illness from the
Norwegian Data Protection Agency so have
appropriate security this is this is
this is what you
security architects should remember at
all times
another important one that also we're
not very good about is that no later
than 72 hours after you know or should
know about a breach of personal data you
have to notify at least the supervising
authority Data Protection Agency and 72
hours if you know what you're doing then
reporting that there was a data breach
after 72 hours it's not a problem if you
don't know what you're doing and there's
the data breach and you don't have any
routines 72 hours is extremely short
deadlines so you have to think about
this so this one is sort of the this is
the slide that you can take a picture of
so to summarize you have to make sure
that if you take consent that it is
freely given that they can understand it
and that they can withdraw it if they no
longer want to consent to the data
processing if you're processing data
based on other reasons than consent you
have to make sure that you're not
processing the more than necessary so if
you if you keep account a data for for
warranty claims you cannot use them for
marketing purpose afterwards so be sure
to do that and the people that you're
registering the information about which
may or may not be the actual user so
people can register information about
others but the person that their
information is about has to be informed
and has to be able to exercise the
rights and the the cool nice one is that
one about data portability and you have
to take security measures you have to
consider what are appropriate security
measures what are appropriate data
minimization measures and you have to
document what decisions you made so it
you might say we don't need to install a
new set of firewalls because that's not
where the attack is going to happen do
you have to make that
consideration you have to decide what's
appropriate and what's not to summarize
when the point of privacy the point of
all of this is to set your users first
this is about the right of our users the
right of the people that we register the
data about and we know that it can go
wrong we've seen it go wrong we're
seeing it go wrong in other parts of the
world so this is actually there is a
reason for this regulation and as more
and more data is registered about us
this becomes a bigger risk to everybody
all the time what is very nice about
these new rules is that they can bite
you because they have a real they have a
real possibility of actually finding
companies and forcing them to act in the
way that we want them to act but it is
we have a lot of things we haven't fixed
yet so we have a lot of debt in our
system we have a lot of security that a
lot of privacy debt in our system we
have to roll up our sleeves the lucky
thing is that their regulations are the
same across all of Europe the
regulations are understandable and
because they are the same and because
are understandable there will be there
are there's emerging and there will be
standards of what's appropriate use
there will be tools that help you out
and there will be knowledge on how to
solve these issues to get started with
helping to solve these issues yourself I
want I would like everybody here to read
article 5 of the GDP R so make sure you
bookmark or remember this address this
is this is what gives you an insight
into how the legislation works and if
you think this is a understandable text
and you can continue with article 6 7 &
8 which are also very understandable
very to the point and you can decide how
much you want to know about it but the
most important thing is to know that the
text is meant for people to read
and the most important thing about when
you're pressing the data is that the
purpose of this is that people's data
should be processed in the way that they
want and they understand the gdpr
effects most of what we built and a
privacy is something that we all have a
stake in but you can understand a
regulation and you can read a little bit
of it so I will be hanging around here a
little bit and then after that I'll be
at my stand if somebody has questions
we're out of time so I don't have much
time for questions now but I'll hang
around efforts I thank you all for
staying awake at a conference where most
people from the outside would find most
subjects boring this may be hip talk
that most developers would find boring
so I'm very grateful that you've kept
your attention to listen to me for this
whole hour thank you very much
[Applause]